[Music]
you know there's an old saying that goes
never bring a knife to a gunfight well
whoever came up with that one never met
simple The Kills through this smokes a
little bit too much to handle no they've
had enough they're already dead at this
point you know about three years ago the
score e-sports took our first stab at a
top-ten knife kills list and csgo but a
lot has changed since then and a lot of
new players have felt the embarrassment
of getting knifed in a pro match so here
is the new improved updated 20/20
version of the top 10 knife kills in
csgo
Gideon's 2 V 3 clutch at ESL pro league
finals which of 2015 was so downright
disgusting we just couldn't think of a
better way to kick off this list with
time winding down and full control of
the a bombsight Dignitas looked poised
to secure the round with ease but with a
knife a pistol and a dream kadian was
not ready to go down lightly Nico gets
Cajun beat KD is coming around the back
side of them gets a glimpse of one it's
gonna be an easy goes Big Daddies what
they needed 14 13 to TSM you waited that
first player to line up he knew that the
flash was in place and look at this
wafer he held his nerves so well flash
comes in takes him down number 9 on our
list comes courtesy of one of CS COEs
most legendary players and we wouldn't
expect any less from this guy
Oh luster through the smokes would you
have it any other way
in the grand finals of ESL pro league
season 11 Europe Russia puts on a
perfect display of sneekybeeky patience
as well as some sto knife work to stab
and dab on most sports maybe a knife is
on the cards let's have a couple nights
oh no five Maps when we get the fnatic
knives out in full force a double he
matches JW's record of two consecutive
knife skills
now don't let this list of 10 knife
kills fool you the rarity of seeing one
in a professional csgo match is what
makes these plays so amazing and that's
why the number 8 spot has to go to
skadoodle and cloud9 who managed to get
not one not two but three knife kills to
clutch out the round pass go off he's
the last one towards site he has a Glock
of course and he may want to hit hand
Jay somehow I would a bullets are under
the knife skadoodle what's he doing a
double knife can he get the third he
gets the right click and rush fine snaps
it's doodle the double knife to hold on
to the site and stop the defuse I'm not
even sure if the player think it was on
the palm that's a legendary player if
it's cool that the game a bloodbath last
second at default at the number 7 spot
Stewie 2k was back to his old
shenanigans against his former and might
be our teammates at the ESL pro league
season 9 finals forced into an eco round
young stewart had to get creative to
land some kills and he did just that
cold Zara's waiting for this push up
Street but he's gonna tuck himself into
the corner cold Zahra though is a bit of
a freak and I have to imagine he's gonna
clear this
oh go god I like yes Stewie's got that
and the follow-up yeah that is now on
its own this particular night play isn't
the craziest thing in the world but you
know what's wild about this one
Stewie made the exact same play against
envyus
a year later with a leash who also
happened to be in the same catwalk
position talk about déjà vu now look
this is looking mold up this is the best
opportunity that'll be given Stewie and
lower dark with a scout I do not know
what he's thinking right now doesn't
know a way and that's an ak-47 and
another one Stewie this is what he
needed to get his life back on track
it'll work Sally didn't drop a single
player ban and all started here with a
knife of course we haven't really seen
any knives today a rush towards the
lower tunnels and Stewie does catch him
off guard
when it comes to csgo
there just aren't a lot of things that
simple can't do which is why he's coming
in at the number 6 spot on our list I
mean come on this guy is a human
highlight reel in the same place
so when it comes to iconic knife kills
the Ukrainian superstar is no stranger
to slicing his way through the
competition which is why this iconic
flying knife kill is something you've
got to see to believe
smoked out bombed down everyone chasing
down gets it and takes him down just
insult to injury this guy's having an
absolute dream of a match and of course
just wants to finish it off in style
coming in at the halfway point on our
list is Guardians do-or-die clutch
against sk-gaming
during the grand final of ESL pro league
season six one round away from victory
sk-gaming had faced client's backs
against the wall and after whipping an
unfortunate shot with his cz at a
crucial point earlier in the round
Guardian was put in a 1v2 scenario with
everything to do I bet you can't guess
what happens next
just the Miss just to play with he
needed to kill Guardians gotta make up
for it he's tapping him but he can't
find it falling on the defuse Paul in
his own infuse the nerves of steel to
run with a knife most people would have
given up when they looked in the air and
taking their hands off the mouse credit
to Guardian for not giving up in my god
if they go to overtime now what a play
the number four spot on our list is
quite possibly the most exciting way to
kick off a game of Counter Strike and it
comes courtesy of flusher and NBK
now look most rush b strats are chaotic
in nature to begin with but this one
from ESL one cologne 2015 i just take
the cake especially when you consider
that MBK and flusher ran out of bullets
and only had one way left to kill each
other
he actually sees two people saw stuff
flying shots
it's down APEC so now they're in the
beep once I flush you're getting a
chance to reload back up he's already
here my Kirishima with a stunning shots
are shot down all of my stew it's now a
4 V 4 JW still alive can you get the
kill on frames rusher in their back
lines he's out of ammo an IV so what's
happening
amazing stuff that with such pandemonium
and look at this moment both flares
running out of ammo on the platform and
NBK taking the knife that amazing stuff
that and what a brilliant start taking
the number three spot on our list are
some of the cheekiest knife kills you'll
ever see from the united masters lead
season two after a 10-5 half Phoenix
decided they wanted to rush fence on the
pistol round but little did they know
there was a player brandishing his knife
and waiting for them on ladder and the
second they jumped down well let's just
say that's when the stabbing started you
get oh my god now slow II may not have
gotten that third kill but talk about
jumping into the blender
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
yet another knife fight from ESL one
cologne 2015 but this time it was
between two of the best offers to ever
touch the game NES and Guardian which is
why when it came down to a 1v1 between
these two everyone was expecting to see
some of the same flicks you know op God
against op God instead we got something
so much better still rattling on through
flame he's gonna push on through but
Kenny's found him and now it's all on
Guardian will you try and hold the off
he gets the shot on sway picks is he
gonna try and go huge hit Kenny s all
sites traded
oh I didn't Lord that was putting
automatic NES picking up so many kills
in that round taking the top spot on our
list is none other than device and his
incredible one-man show
during the ECS season two semi-finals
it's a boys night ghouls gonna win then
there is a knife because the background
see boys would do in one round now we
understand that in a game of
professional counter-strike aces do
happen but what happens when you have
none in the chamber and two left to kill
well in this play device says no bullets
no problem as he guts the remaining
sk-gaming players to cap off a truly
spectacular ace four ranges well with it
walking out blocks right position said
he would be there across fire it's the
border folks go tonight
cool gonna win vault but then there is a
knife because the fights have background
device we're doing one round
that's insane replan device right now
what the hell just happened that their
bodies have been things double to kills
the pistol and knives to the what is
going on as such huge pits around as
well like you said boxes the prime
position lock it down it looked like it
was going very successfully let's photo
have any pools on the phone runs out of
ammo
okay oh my god there's one keep going
why no boom oh my god he was it wasn't
even that he switched to it for a call
he was out of them on the whole time
somebody's this guy gone now alright
guys that is it for the top ten knife
kills in csgo now if you did enjoy this
video or hell even if you didn't go
ahead and stab that subscribe button and
hey while you're at it go on over to
twitch.tv slash the score esports and
gut the follow button and turn on
notifications I'm done with the knife
buns now look what I found recently
this old-ass 1996 Nintendo published
guide to the Super Mario RPG for Super
Nintendo
Yoshi's badass gangland cousin couldn't
forget mama mole you all know mama mole
and here we come to my favorite of all
mister shark in a cave classic Mario
character